hi I am play Bella rain and the Minister
of Finance of Chile and he's gonna be
answering what is the main reason why
you're active crisis and that questions
from YouTube well there's several
reasons why European crisis their
economic reasons and economic reasons
point to levels of spending government
spending that went beyond what the ateva
Belize of the governments were so you
spend beyond your income then you
accumulate debt and you're incurring in
higher deficits because you need to pay
interest on your debt and that's like a
like a snowball that keeps growing and
in some cases several countries arrive
two levels of government deficits of ten
percent of gross domestic product and
that is was clearly unsustainable so
countries needed to implement fiscal
adjustments and fiscal adjustments are
costly and in the short term they are
probably contractionary so you have the
need to adjust fiscally it does
adjustment means cutting spending
raising taxes at a moment when the
economy is weak and there is a problem
that is the economic reason and part of
this may be a response to the crisis of
2008-2009 when governments tried to
stimulate their economies but then the
stimulate the stimulus package needs to
be phased out and when you face that
you're left with a higher level of
government debt that is the economic
reason but there's a different reason we
know or pretty much know when we have to
do in terms or what needs to be done in
terms of solving the economic problem
but then the second issue is political
and it's the political agreement and the
ability of the countries of the EU and
mainly the European the eurozone because
those are 17 members of the eurozone to
act together and to act decisively in a
timely manner and that is what has been
lacking so I think the very important
part in the solution to this problem
having laid out where the problem is is
the decision and to act together and to
act decisively in the
or term otherwise if we don't act I
never countries don't act in a
reasonable period of time what we're
gonna have is a much bigger problem in
the future
the solution is costlier by the moment
if you fail to act what you can act on
is a bigger problem